foreign
Luke here at the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel and today I'm taking 14 people
camping in the deep snow here in the
mountains of Alaska and I have got to
build the ultimate deep snow survival
complex to house all of them
I think you guys can enjoy this come
along for the ride
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
well it's 8 A.M and I'm up in the
mountains I'm gonna eat my Wheaties and
take my Advil because I got a lot of
shoveling and a lot of setting up to do
for the rest of the group arrives
there's about 170 centimeters or about
five and a half feet of snow on the
ground here we got a lot of digging
ahead of us
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
look at this guys we are hauling butt
man pop some Advil in me and I can get
things done all right let's keep going
it's going pretty fast
foreign
we'll check it out guys
I think I just made an open pit diamond
mine
oh that's crazy
the snow is a lot deeper than I thought
tell you what I'm about six and a half
feet tall with my boots on so the snow's
just a hair under six and a half feet
deep
and
at the top of the wall it's about nine
feet
well we made a good start but we're not
done yet
it snowed about three inches since I got
here
foreign
foreign
[Music]
yeah what do you guys think it is
it kind of feels all nice get out of the
wind doesn't it yeah wow it's so warm
down here what do you think what do you
think of this be cool you guys
well how about this let's let's put you
in the uh would that be the southern
Wing yes yeah we'll put you in the
southern wing of the complex look at you
guys
I love filming you guys shoveling it's
so much better than doing it myself oh
yeah
this is quite the load
look at that welcome to the ice cold
ground
hey guys
what do you think is that did I do it
big enough
I guess I don't need my shovel well I
better get going because I need to get
my tent up before my wife and kids
arrive they expect a certain amount of
comfort when they go camping with me
okay
foreign
oh looks like my family's here his party
can get started
oh dressing boys it's not easy
the hardest part of camping Jake are you
excited yes we're done with digging and
Becca just arrived so it's a flurry of
activity here we're gonna try to get
dinner ready I think everyone's worked
up a healthy appetite we're gonna bust
this baby out
yes
we are gonna make yakisoba Japanese
stir-fry and to say I brought a lot is a
gross understatement 2.99 for this
entire thing a little bunch of ground
pork with fennel seed and curry powder
and lots of other spices got some cubed
pork belly or lardens next man
all right guys I can talk the talk but
can I walk the walk
stand back right
luckily I've got a long handle spoon so
when it splatters I can be safe
so good
wow
there you go guys the Caribou first
keeping your bums warm
yeah what do you think it is babe this
is amazing
like
okay
oh man that's looking good dude
all right you guys want some food yeah
okay hold out a plate there we go
you want to eat them that looks pretty
good actually the problem with that big
Wok is it made the food look smaller now
that I'm putting it on people's plates
I'm like this is enormous amount of food
[Music]
you get some footage of us all eating
Luke right now oh
all right guys well we're done with
dinner and we want to get the fire
started but we didn't bring any kindling
and we forgot to bring an ax so we're
gonna show you how to fix this problem
because it's not the first time I've
done this
on fire
no why would you be cold
[Music]
that is hot water for your hot chocolate
Okay who wants hot chocolate oh shocker
Becca would you like some hot apple
cider I would love some thank you
everybody
is that keeping your hands warm
yeah are they doing well I'm doing great
good
Ness
[Music]
[Applause]
Nathan I think you're steaming this is
my hot chocolate okay yes but just back
away from the fire oh yes yes you are
warm
okay go over there before you melt
Nathan Hey guys does anybody want to eat
marshmallows maybe more
yeah we can do s'mores hey here come get
your marshmallow sticks
yeah you should hashtag solo it's
shedding it's skin right now
Jake are you loving that yeah you are
how you like that Nutella s'more
all right guys I gotta I gotta show you
one feature of our ice compound here
let's uh
check it out
we've got a bathroom
got our toilet paper
a little Camp toilet
not too bad huh
all right guys we're getting ready for
bed here and uh we gotta make sure
everyone's nice and warm so we're gonna
boil up a big pot of water here and fill
up a whole bunch of water bottles with
boiling hot water so we can shove it in
people's sleeping bags and keep them
warm all right we got plenty of bottles
here
all right trying to change your clothes
and get into a sleeping bag in a cold
tent is pretty miserable so I've got a
little buddy heater here a little
propane here I'm gonna preheat the tent
so the kids when they get into their
sleeping bag it's all nice and warm and
then in the morning do the same thing
you just don't want to sleep with it on
because carbon monoxide can be an issue
all right so we've got the adhesive body
warmers have you ever used those they're
a giant sticker okay you stick them to
your undergarments and then put your
clothes over the top of them and they
work amazing well they last 12 hours
they take about 45 minutes to get warmed
up especially if they're starting cold
so if the kids are going to go to bed
the next hour maybe it's now is the time
to start slapping the stickers on them
Tom are you just like a little Captain
Kirk you need to take your shirt off
cover your eyes
are you are you guys getting hot in
there
too hot in the hot tent yes
here let me check it out here
is it it's a sauna in here
[Music]
[Laughter]
guys it's flashlight time you gotta find
them now before it gets too dark to find
them
what's that babe
oh oh you sweet woman you I thought you
might
what is this
it's gonna go ahead and fill up these
bottles full of hot water before we get
ready to go to bed
we go put these in the sleeping bags
it'll keep them warm all night long as
long as the lids are on tight all right
my sweet wife is putting the boys to bed
I love you you're a hero
I'm sorry I called them I only have two
serious winter bags for boys and so for
Jacob I'm going to take this 15 degree
Big Agnes bag and I've got a slightly
bigger version I'm going to shove one
inside the other and I should keep them
plenty warm tonight
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
it's late but we got everybody in 110.
going to bed I'll see you guys in the
morning
I gotta get some hot chocolate going and
a fire going so that everyone gets warm
as soon as they wake up
got a lot of snow last night
[Applause]
man we got a lot of snow last night
check it out
bats tent is barely visible
look at that yeah we got a good four
inches last night
foreign
's getting up
you guys digging out over there
well good morning how did you guys sleep
everybody Warp
you're warm good
form I did I said more once you guys are
all dressed up we'll have some fresh
donuts for everybody
how did you guys sleep last night well
amazing I don't know about her no I was
good you're good but the body piece of
warmers those were incredible you know
it's amazing how much just a little bit
of external heat makes a difference
right yeah they make a big difference
those body warmers are nice you guys had
the water bottles too oh yeah the water
bottles that's that's always a game
changer Hey Mimi did you sleep well
yeah were you warm yeah good good glad
to hear it sounds like everybody did
pretty well last night did awesome well
listen guys would you like some hot
donuts yeah yeah I think we should make
some hot donuts let's see if I can do
this without the oil exploding in my
face
oh there's peanut oil is so Frozen it's
all Gloppy
foreign
[Music]
hold that with your hands I gotta cook
bud
who wants who wants Donuts
yeah
Jacob do you like your donut
what do you think you guys like them
they good nice warm campfire donut
crunchy and hot steamy and sugary
it's worth getting out of your tent for
all that chocolate diet just going out
the window right
you got there ah it's a bear a bear
do you guys sleep on that last night yep
Naomi did ah it's nice and warm all
right you guys ready for some breakfast
burritos yeah
[Music]
yum yum breakfast burrito yeah
[Music]
well I'm out here cooking breakfast the
kids are out riding on snow machines
they're living their best life
mango salsa the stuff in the Mason jar
is hot
you guys you like the burritos the good
they're delicious good good was great
calories don't count when winter camping
well guys we got breakfast in our belly
and we got a lot of packing up to do so
the kids are gonna go off sledding and
playing around a little bit while we do
that you guys want to go sledding
you tried to walk up there
[Applause]
yeah are you gonna let it off the roof
no don't kill Jacob Nathan
okay you guys taking off take it off
dude oh well thanks for coming we had a
great time it was awesome pleasure well
guys we're all packed up
look at this place
man
it's turned out to be quite the shelter
a lot of snow got moved by hand it's
time to get all my gear home I gotta go
dry it all out oh
all right I'll see you at home babe
it
oh the snow got into everything every
bin has water in it every bag even the
stuff we didn't use got wet so we gotta
pull it all out to dry it all out clean
it and then put it all away that's
camping anyway but I hope you guys have
enjoyed this video I hope you enjoyed
watching this Liz if you want to see
more camping videos from the outdoor
Boys YouTube channel make sure to check
out our camping video playlist we have
over 60 camping videos there I'll put a
link in the description below and don't
forget to click subscribe we put out new
videos every Saturday morning I'll see
you guys then
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every Saturday morning and hit
that Bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching